Iquitos is inaccessible by road you can
only get there by plane or boat
the Peruvian city with 400,000
inhabitants is tucked away in the middle
of the Amazonian rainforest the people
of the rainforest are only allowed to
hunt for themselves and their families
in Peru commercial wildlife hunting is
banned and yet it's possible to buy all
sorts of endangered wildlife live or
freshly-cooked at the famous Belen
market I recently talked to a former
wildlife trader and I said well at least
there's less illegal trade of bush meat
and she said we just don't let the
public see it these days when someone
says they want something specific then
he makes sure to hide it away in his
home gouda lunch Parra has lived in
Iquitos for 30 years she runs a refuge
for threatened species at the market in
Berlin she buys fruit and vegetables for
her animals the jungle surrounding
Iquitos has been over hunted these days
the wild animals killed by poachers are
very young there's a tiny caiman on the
table there and you can see how small it
is dead of course probably 2 or 3 months
old it's terrible but people buy
something like that the animals are
often killed before they've had a chance
to reproduce species are dying out this
is ghastly I don't even know what sort
of meat it is such a vaca
that's even worse that's Tapia which is
threatened with extinction it must have
been very young because Tapia grow to
quite a size they can weigh up to 300
kilos but the problem is they don't
begin to reproduce until they're 6 or 7
she's in a hurry
the animals are waiting for feeding time
this is the Western port of Iquitos
guten spammer has to cross the Rio non
i2 pathway kocha founded 24 years ago as
a butterfly sanctuary her refuge is in
the middle of the jungle
today the Philippine - Ozzy animal
orphanage is also home to threatened
birds and mammals they live here in
conditions that are species appropriate
this Jaguar has lived here since it was
a cub when illegal traders simply threw
it away it was in a wooden crate tied
with barbed wire and it was thrown into
the water in the harbour here by someone
who was trading illegally with
indigenous people and selling all sorts
of animals but he didn't sell the Jaguar
and it couldn't even stand on its feet
anymore a Jaguar requires a diet made of
up to 70% red meat or it suffers kidney
damage Jaguars are endangered because
they're losing their habitat they're
loners both the male and the female of
the species needs fifty square
kilometers to itself to find what it
needs to feed on but nowadays there are
too many streets and pipelines and they
don't want to cross them once the godson
doesn't list at the market in Berlin
traders so slabs of Tabler meat Gudrun
Shiva has tappers in her animal
sanctuary chi bola was seized by the
environmental police because tourists
had reported seeing him he was held on a
float in the river as an attraction his
keepers only gave him leftovers to eat
so he was suffering from a damaged liver
but he made a good recovery he was still
striped when he first arrived when tap
ears are young they look like wild boar
even though there are completely
different species they're actually most
closely related to horses top ears need
to live in areas with a good source of
water these animals managed to survive
the Ice Age but within just 15 years
humans have made them an endangered
species in Papeete Wazza visitors can't
Tours that raise awareness of the
Tapia's plight a total of 55 monkeys
live here including 10 balls or carries
their population is also declining
rapidly in South America woolly monkeys
meanwhile make popular pets when a
monkey has sold commercially the traders
kill its mother so that it's docile this
one his name is Chi still has 3 bullets
in his arm you can feel them but there's
no need for an operation so they shoot
the mother and then they sell the infant
when they arrive here they're in a
terrible state they're malnourished
dehydrated they often have broken bones
they've often suffered Falls when their
mother was shot back in Iquitos the
Amazon rescue centre works on species
conservation rescuing various threatened
animals that are vital to the ecosystem
including manatees a marine mammals
sometimes known as the sea cow manatees
are the largest mammals in the Amazon
oddly enough the least well-known we
begin our work here 80% of the
inhabitants of Iquitos were completely
unfamiliar with this species baby
manatee would end up in their fishing
nets and people would keep them as pets
but then the manatees would die in
captivity the Amazon rescue center is
the only place in the world where
rescued manatees are raised and then
released back into the wild
they take a lot of looking after the
calves need to be fed every two hours
for the first two years
they're lactose intolerant so they're
given a special milk imported from the
US one manatee costs the center ten
thousand dollars per year the animals
have a gentle trusting nature
para poder tomatilloes Hunter's kill
them when they come up for air by
sticking wooden pegs at their snouts a
terrible death for a beautiful
good-natured creature that plays an
important role in the ecosystem
once the manatees are weaned off milk
they can start to eat aquatic lettuce
manatees feed on aquatic vegetation like
this here and other plants that cover
the surface of the river in the places
where the manatees have died out this
vegetation starts to proliferate and the
inhabitants suffer because they have
less fish and they can no longer go out
on their boats because of all the plant
growth clogging up the water the
rainforest of Iquitos is a vast biotope
if its natural balance is threatened it
has consequences for wildlife and
inhabitants in the whole region
you